هنا الان في مطار رونالدو ان في الحقيقه
الاوضاع افضل بكثير من اليومين السابقين
اللذان يسبقان ليله الدول ليله عيد
الميلاد المجيد همم من همم نحو 5
تاخير والغاء لرحلات جويه يوم الجمعه من
يوم نتحدث هنا في مطار رونالدو
طبعا الوضع هنا افضل همم بسبب صغر المطار
هو المطار المحاضره للعاصمه واشنطن فيما
طائرات اخرى على الوضع يختلف نسيمه في
المطارات الكبيره مثل المطار اتلانتسكو
ومطر شيكاغو ولا سيما تلك الرحلات
المتوجهه نحو الولايات الشماليه التي
ضربها همم هذا الانفجار القطبي كما يوصف
خاصه منطقه غرب ولايه نيويورك وتحديدا همم
مدينه بافلو- جاورها الذي تعرضت الى همم
العاصفه الاسوء وهي وهنا المفارقه ان هذه
المدينه صهيب هي مدينه مجهزه لمواجهه
العواصف الكبيره لديهم الادوات وديهم
الامكانيات لمواجهه كذا عواصف ولكن مع ذلك
هذه العاصفه كانت اقوى من كل التجهيزات
التي كانت سابقا نحن هنا اذا سنتجول قليلا
الاوضاع تبدو هادئه اليوم مقارنه كما قلنا
باليومين السابقين حيث اضطر العديده من
المسافرين الى البقاء في المطار
حجز فنادق في منطقه قريبه اليوم الرحلات
كانت اسهل بسبب طبعا تحسن الاجواء نوعا ما
مقارنه بين يومين الماضيين اليوم على
الصعيد الوطني تم الغاء همم نحو 1600 رحله
وتم تاجيل همم نحو ثلاثه 13 رحله هنا في
داخل المتحده همم سالنا بعد الاشخاص هنا
تحدثنا معهم طبعا هناك همم حالات احباط
الكثيرون هنا في الولايات المتحده من خلال
هذه العطله لقضاء عطله عيد الميلاد ونسيمه
ليله عيد الميلاد يوم عيد الميلاد العشاء
والغداء مع اقربائهم الكثير منهم اضطروا
للبقاء في المطارات او بعضهم قرر يعني ان
يستاجر سياره ويسافر بالبر ولكن ايضا كان
هناك مخاطر بسبب الجديد الذي اصاب الطرقات
في العديد من الولايات هنا نسيمه في
الولايات
الوسطى التي ايضا لم تضربها العاصفه
الثلجيه ولكن البرد القارس الذي ادى الى
ااه هطول الامطار جليديه والى تكون طبقه
جليديه على الطرق في العديد منها